hi everyone it's Jerry I have an
instructive game to share with you from
the 2011 Amber rapid tournament on the
white end Vladimir kramnick playing
against Magnus
Carlson in this one we have a simple
fight over a single Square in the middle
game it's a 31 mover and it breaks down
the three phases really well for about
the first 10 moves it's the opening and
about the next 10 it's this middle game
fight over D5 and then it's on to the
ending now this initial stage is
non-confrontational let's see the setups
for each a bit of timing here by Carlson
who goes with a queen's Indian
formation he ensures his Bishop is on
this diagonal before the Knight can move
to unleash the G2
Bishop castles E6 Knight
C3 met with A6
A6 secures a queen post on
C7 double fing ketto for kramnick eight
Moves In what can we
say well the kings are cozy the minor
pieces that have been deployed are on
excellent squares and every pawn move
that has been played is with a
purpose the C pawns are excellent
contributors to key Center squares each
in a spot to combat potential Pawn Duos
in the event of D4 Black's already there
similarly D5 white is
there all right from here it is
E3 and
D6 a new square is produced for the
queen Knight black does not want to
obstruct the
Bishop from here D4 this is right about
where the middle game kicks off I'd say
first case coming up now where a piece
moves for a second time Knight E4 met
with D5 and this is where the fight now
begins over the the D5
Square what is this fight about exactly
what does white want out of the D5
Square what does black
want well white wants a white piece to
occupy
D5 black wants a white Pawn to occupy
D5 why well in the game Knight takes
Knight is played If instead for example
this capture is made this would be
excellent for white to have a piece
occupy
D5 why well this piece can always move
and when it moves we could see major
pieces exerting pressure on this
ready-made Target on
D6 If instead a pawn is there this Pawn
can't move there's not going to be as
much pressure now on D6 it's not as
accessible so this for now at least is
really the main focus the potential
vulnerability of the D6 Pawn there are
structural changes that come with this
capture and majorities are created but
for now the attention should really be
on the D6
Pawn okay in this game it is first
Knight takes Knight removing the
defender of D5 and only now do we we
have the capture notice kramnick is not
so quick to occupy this square with a
pawn instead he withdraws the Knight
throws the pawn in a
pin okay we continue with Bishop F6 dark
Square Bishop exchange and the reply
here is Rook
C1 if white goes in for the piece
recapture on D5 now it's not good
why not let's see what this looks like
if white tries to occupy this square
with a piece The Rook would fall it's
true Black's Rook would fall but black
is coming out ahead winning a pawn ready
to win a second and then bolt with the a
pawn so it's not a good choice to make
this capture instead Rook C1 gets out of
the line of
fire now white is ready to take on this
square with a p
black adds a Defender though Queen
F5 two pieces on it two pieces on
it if white starts taking on this Square
eventually black can force it where the
pawn has to
recapture Knight D3 comes this guy still
can't move there's still the pin Knight
D7 though and in the game here we have
Knight
F4 inste instead of that move if white
takes on D5 black should not recapture
that would be a losing move a good move
here would be Knight F6 what's the
problem if you meet this capture with
Bishop
takes the queen is the defender of the
bishop and she can be deflected with G4
Queen G5 is met with F4 the bishop will
fall next and queen E6 can be met with
Knight F4 a fork
so in this game it is Knight F4 Knight
F6 every piece except for the Rooks are
currently on
D5 we continue with Rook E1 Rook e 8 and
H3 looking to distract or deflect the
queen from observing
D5 another Defender however is now added
to D5 Rook
E5 G4 and now now Queen D7 this last
move has unpinned the pawn the bishop is
now defended and black is finally ready
to make
capture I should also note Rook E5 is
not just there to defend or exert
pressure on this square but defends
against a possible Pawn push stabilizes
you might say the Knight on
F6 finally we have the captures on
D5 how would you recapture in this
position are you taking with the Knight
or the bishop feel free to pause the
video okay in the game Carlson takes
with the bishop this is considered
best uh if you take with the Knight I'm
not sure how great this bishop is
doesn't have a whole lot of
Mobility um so he takes with the bishop
keeps this Knight around to watch over
the king side do know there are some
holes here on the king side makes some
sense maybe to keep a piece around there
and also when you look at it maybe
there's a good
chance that you could get into a
superior minor piece position as black
there are a lot of Pawns on the same
color as this light Square
Bishop now a reason white doesn't take
with the bishop here is because the
position would be simplifying a bit more
and this majority on the Queen side that
is now created because of this last
capture 3 to2 this majority
only uh increases in value as the pieces
decrease additionally to give up the F
kod Bishop when there's these holes over
here not a wise choice so this is
considered best to recapture with the
pawn right here and the fight over D5 is
essentially over now so where does our
our attention turn
next
well the focus here is on the
majorities does this mean we start going
with our own majority right now well not
so fast because with this last capture
white now has a majority in the center
so black must be attentive to the
following idea F4 E4 and
E5 it can easily collapse for
black he's not going to let that happen
though he kicks off with Queen E7 there
is no F4 the E Pawn will fall but
kramnick puts himself in position to
play F4 now that this is
defended in comes G5 an excellent
multi-purpose move black has now a
flight square and combats the idea of f4
four he's ready to take and white will
not be able to recapture he would lose a
rook another benefit of having the
Knight still around on the king side now
that G5 is in especially are these ideas
to pry at this G4 Pawn what you might
describe as an overextended Pawn there
are these ideas to play
H5 and maybe force black to take away
from the
center okay in any case G5 excellent
move here the reply is King F1 adding
some defense to E1 making F4 now
possible how to combat this idea this is
where it gets a bit tricky there isn't a
way to defend F4 directly but check this
move out Knight
D7 this opens up F6 for the
Queen the reply here is A4 if white goes
in for F4 here Queen F6 and white has a
problem now on F4 it's
pinned how would white defend the
pressure on
F4 uh if you play Queen to
D2 uh black can increase the pressure
here if I carried out a few more moves
let's see how quickly this position can
collapse for white we can have a bunch
of exchanges now and in the end black is
going to come out ahead you take with
the Queen the F Pawn Falls and if you
take with the king the queen turns into
Pac-Man Queen A1 check there goes the a
there goes the B you could
resign so F4 is no good instead white
clamps down on Black's majority each
side combating one another's
majorities the reply here Rook to
f8 this is considered one of the best
moves May seems surprising because this
Pawn is hanging white takes it what is
the idea this is considered the best
move what white plays here to take with
the a pawn but now check this out we
have F5 the f file is getting peeled
open cram Nick's reply here is a
blunder he plays Queen to B7 and couple
moves later ends up undoing that move
what is considered best here for white
is to either to draw the queen or get
the King off of the f file let me just
put on one of the moves Queen here the
reply in both cases by the engine is to
go with F4 in this position and even
though black is down at pawn it likes
black better primarily because if
there's a black Pawn on F4 white can't
play F4 himself what does that mean this
Knight will soon be able to occupy a
tremendous Square on E5 an unassailable
Knight not the move played though no
Queen E2 no King G1 instead there's a
pin against the Knight but this pin is
easily addressed with first a capture on
G4 this last move has pinned the F Pawn
and black simply gets that pawn right
back with Rook takes E3 and is simply
winning the reply here Queen to
A6 uh what else can you play here if
you're taking here the queen
recaptures yeah no help here to take the
Rook on
E3 instead it is Queen
A6 Queen F6 m one
threat Rook E2 to
defend Knight E5 amazing piece and one
more move Rook on C to E1 and before
Carlson can even make his next move
kramnick
resigned why there's one too many good
moves here for black Balan material but
this Knight is not a three-pointer that
is for sure Superior minor piece
position you can take on G4 or even B3
this is this would be my prefer to take
the B Pawn defend your only base point
and next up you could take the G pawn
and black maintains this iron grip in a
position like this over all of these
weakened dark squares in White's camp
but the game goes no further that move
was played and then kramnick threw in
the
towel so what did you think of this one
anyhow Feel Free as you usual to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comment section below I hope you enjoyed
it and maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care
bye